hello and welcome to Eureka lab my name
is Bethany brookshire i'm the author of
this blog and i'm here to talk to you
about what it's like to love science to
work in science and to find out what
careers in science technology
engineering and math are all about
welcome to our second google hangout
talking about science careers today i am
here with dr. calif wilson a
post-doctoral researcher in immunology
he's at the University of Pennsylvania
School of Medicine in the Abramson's
family Cancer Research Institute um and
he's on Twitter as at hey dr. Wilson and
he's here to talk to us today about what
he does in his job why he loves science
and why you should love science too so
hello Calif hello are you doing pretty
good thanks for coming on wanted to be
here so i just wanted to ask what is
your job now what is a postdoc and what
do you do a postdoc is think about it
like a internship or like a
apprenticeship so after we get our
doctorate we need a little bit more
training so this is an opportunity for
us to do something different than what
we did for the work we did for our PhD
to research to get our PhD okay and so
you study immunology what exactly do you
study so but first let me define women
ology is this is basically the study of
the balance between disease and health
um so the body is always in this process
of being healthy and fighting off any
types of diseases whether it's cancer or
something from within or an infection
from bacteria parasite of viruses so
something from the outside and
specifically always fighting off
diseases yeah there's always a balance
your body's in like this constant battle
throughout your entire life of trying to
do everything it needs to do to stay
healthy but also
keep things out but but specifically
where my work does is I I work to teach
t-cells how to find cancer cells and HIV
infected cells and kill them so what r T
cells t-cells are a type of white blood
cell so T cells will coordinate the
response today so they're basically like
let's say the quarterback of the unit
football so like the quarterback of the
immune system of and if you're in the
basketball it's like the point guard so
the point guard or the quarterback kind
of calls the plays you know get
everybody lined up correctly and and
then say okay this is what i need to do
you need to be here do this to execute
this play so it's all a would be immune
response okay so by coordinating
together um the t-cells say as like the
quarterback they like organized the
defense against the bacteria or
infection or in this case you're looking
for organizing a defense against cancer
and HIV yes that's pretty cool so that's
what you do overall what do you do like
on a day-to-day basis what's your life
like so daily I get in the morning and
so there's always some t cells and
culture um what does my n so we will
back up for a second so I mentioned that
we teach t-cells how to find and kill
cancer in hiv-infected cells and so what
we do is from the research side is we
have healthy people that come in and
donate blood and then we take their take
their blood and then and we call
fractionated so we put we take the blood
and divided into different parts the
part of the blood that I get is T cells
so some people may order B cells they
may order um other types of white blood
cells I use T cells from actual people
so that's called primary cells
and so I'll take those so for instance
today's Tuesday put an order in i'll get
cells later today I'll take them and put
them in a plate or dish like petri dish
and culture give them put them in like a
solution that has nutrients in it and
other things that stimulate the cells to
to get them to do what I want to want to
do cool so people actually come in and
give blood for science so where does
that blood just does it just come from a
blood bank or do they you have
volunteers or no this isn't from a blood
bank so we actually have people that are
called the phrases healthy donor so the
people that they don't have any known
diseases no cancers infections and so
they come in and I think it's maybe
every six weeks or so they cycle through
they'll give blood on Tuesday sometimes
on Wednesday but tuesdays and thursdays
so it's it's this these donations are
just for us so it's just for science
it's not someone just donate blood for
hospitals and then we get a portion that
this is just for the research that's
really cool have you ever donated blood
for things actually I have so let's see
a couple years ago we were doing they
were doing like a larger scale
experiment two before a clinical trial
they want to get as many different
people as possible so I gave blood to
that too so can be test so i think uh
it's probably published somewhere i know
exactly with my cells in that so so
someone who has access to my DNA out
there well from our research group like
that's dangerous though I mean isn't it
dangerous to you have to wear like lots
of equipment yeah so so we have a tissue
culture room that specifically for uh
well you can artistically room because
some people are working with live HIV so
HIV they can affect you we wear gown
and you know double glove where were
high protection and you know we make
sure that everything gets pleased and
you tried not to do anything that's
going to expose you but that is a danger
if unknowingly if a pitiful excuse not
patient but a donor has contracted an
infection let's say like hepatitis or
something in a they don't know it and
they donate blood and then you know
someone comes in they can do it but we
have you know you get vaccinated for a
couple forms of hepatitis and some other
things that help you Bob be safe on the
cell so there's always safety protocols
as long as you're doing you're supposed
to be doing and you're doing a safe way
taking your time and being careful uh
it's pretty easy to work with okay so
what do you do like on a daily basis
what kind of so you know you get
yourselves and then what happens so so
I'll get the cells and what we have to
do what we do first is activate them so
we have a small metal beads that has
proteins coated to them these proteins
call antibodies and so we mixed in with
the cells and then to activate the cells
the cool thing that we do anything like
a trigger for teeth oh well so these
antibodies are too they are they they
connect will bind to proteins on the t
cell surface that nice these proteins on
its on the t cell are where activate
them so it's scott like the it's
mimicking the t cell receptor or the the
portion of the t cell that was kind of a
handshake so whenever whenever he has a
excuse me the immune response in order
for a t-cell to know what's going on it
basically goes around and shakes hands
with other cells in the immune system
and so so imagine if you had a coin or
something in your hand and you shook
somebody's hand and based on what was in
your hand it would determine how you
responded to it and so that so t cells
basically go around and shake hands with
other cells called antigen presenting
cells and he's enter presenting cells
that the say for instance if there's
bacteria they'll take the bacteria and a
golfer like an amoeba uh and then it'll
pull the bacteria inside itself and then
chop it up like on a cutting board in
the kitchen but there it's more a little
more complicated than that it'll take
portions of that bacteria and put it on
the protein and then that protein will
be like one hand one hand and then the
tissot come over with this other hand
and it will shake hands and the tissot
say oh okay I know what that is so now
this is how I'm going to coordinate a
response to that um thing signals along
exactly so in order for the t-cell to
know what it needs to do it has to get
the information so it's a way of
communicating to the T cell here's a
problem this is what the problem is and
this is what and then the t-cell decides
okay this is how we're going to deal
with it okay so now that you've
activated your t-cells you know by
making them handshake what else what
happened so we wait for 24 to 36 hours
and we we do something that's cool to
the T so so we actually take a form of
HIV to put jeans into the t-cell right
so JV is the protein that produces that
can cause people to suffer from AIDS
exactly so but but but this form of HIV
isn't it it does not like it doesn't it
won't make more HIV so it's basically
it's it's just a way to to put a gene to
take a gene that t-cell doesn't have and
give it to it and so I mentioned before
and teaching the t-cells how to kill HIV
and cancer so wanted it so let's talk
about cancer for a second one of the
issues with cancer is cancers from
within your own body in general your
body does not attack itself so I
mentioned so if you think about the
t-cell going around shaking hands one of
the things that happen is it shakes
hands with cells and it says okay hey
all right you're cool you should be here
um this isn't a problem
recognized I knew you yeah it's
recognized as what we call self or part
of you and so since the cancer cell is
from your own cells often times t cells
and other cells in your body have a
difficult time recognizing the cancer as
a problem and so that's how cancers grow
they have ways of hiding themselves it's
kind of like they they're stealthy yeah
and so what we do is we'll we'll give a
gene or put DNA into the T cell and then
that DNA is like a specific type of
glove so remember before with the the
handshake so what we actually do is give
a glove that can actually recognize
cancer so we tell so we tell the T cell
that now you have the ability to see
this specific type of cancer or the
contour if you duck think about HIV we
give it a different type of glove or
gene that says now you can see HIV and
so yeah and so in its in its and s call
um that's called genetic engineering so
before we give the t-cell those jeans it
does not have the ability to see a
certain cancers or HIV so we give it
that ability by giving it DNA or jeans
and the form of HIV that we use in a lab
it's just a way to to give HIV that the
DNA or give it the specific gloves to
see cancer or HIV so what you do is you
take the virus HIV which can inject DNA
in the cells and use exactly it gives
DNA tu p'tee cell and the missile has
that DNA like a glove and can be like
cancer cell I see you exactly exactly
that's awesome yeah it's like you can't
hide anymore we know you here we're
going to find you and you have to go
cool so how did so you started so you're
working with you know cancer now you're
working with you know you're using HIV
you're using human cells and laboratory
how did you get to where you are now how
did you become a postdoc how did you get
into science as a career what steps did
you take so I going back to high school
I was very interested in biology did
well in biology classes and my other
science and science and math classes and
when I went to college I actually
started off as an undecided major and
part of the reason was so I had this
interesting background where I did well
in science technology engineering
mathematics courses or stem but i also
had experience in a couple different
phases of construction so i learned how
to operate heavy equipment bulldozers
and stuff I learned how to do carpentry
and build cabinets and build houses so I
had this like this you know kind of
divergent interests or you know these
interested are like very separate
although mathematics and a lot of
science is used in construction we don't
generally think about that way and so
while I was in undergrad at Alcorn State
University back home in Mississippi I
started again excelled in the classes I
decided to major in biology and like
most students when you think about
biology what we're mostly familiar with
is becoming a physician or nurse or you
know maybe a science teacher so so that
the types of careers are that you think
about was limited and I had a
interesting experience is in that a
professor from the University of
Wisconsin came down and gave a science
talk and it was very exciting and you
know he was studying um this parasite
that's found in in Africa and the
parasites
given to people so it lives in a fly and
if the fly bites someone the person gets
the parasite and they get what's called
sleeping sickness and so I was really
interested in it and I talked to him
about it and said well why don't you
come up in work in the lab or summer Wow
yeah and it was like yeah it was like
whoa okay really you know that's like so
the reason I was excited about that is a
remember in high school and in college
looking in the back of the textbooks and
after each chapter their references and
so those references are for research
papers that were read in the author the
books got them together and this and
wrote it in a way that kind of in a
coherent way so you can understand
exactly what's going on the biology book
but they're the papers that you know
determine what we know about biology
there the research not exactly so yeah
so now I'm that's one of the things that
I'm doing i'm generating research papers
that one day will help contribute to you
know therapy for HIV and cancer and some
work idea is a graduate student the
general knowledge of how the immune
system works and so you know so i go to
wisconsin you know I new to this having
worked in a lab you know it took a lot
of time to teach me now this is the
coolest thing and so very in very few
times in life do you actually do
something that that's a part of like
this bigger picture and you're the only
person that knows it so I didn't
experiment we what we're doing is
infecting mice with this parasite called
trypanosomes and after doing experiment
and collecting the data analyzing it you
know I'm looking at it I'm like wait a
minute I'm the only person in the world
that knows it it's like what like this
is data you know it's like it's you know
it's it's like wow like no one else in
the world knows it I did experiment I'm
the only person that knows this and it
worked and it's like like that
was like the Eureka moment is like wait
a minute spinning a career doing
something that no one else knows and and
like that's what science is you're
constantly trying to answer questions
that have not been answered before so
you're spending your career creating new
knowledge new exactly Oh buddy knew
before yeah and like that's that's
that's the coolest thing about it you
know like that's everyone like when I
think about it's like really exciting
it's like they're if you take a textbook
there's information in a textbook
however let's say the text book was
written in 2012 so their thing there
their experiments and research papers
that will come out after that text books
has been published and what will happen
is the next time that they make an
addition a new version that textbook
that new information may be in there so
you might be in a tech specs of me I
hope so and it would be cool you know is
to be you know referencing a textbook
because as you know if it's in a book
that's like that's a big deal it's going
to be around for a while so it's very
it's so cool but you you know you really
love science in the process of discovery
are there any things about being a
scientist that are very difficult that
are not not so positive ah failing so so
generally the there's a lot of failure
in size and that's because you know you
think about how you're going to set up
an experiment and you create a
hypothesis and you know you're trying to
disprove that hypothesis so so basically
you're trying to work to create a
failure and sometimes experiments don't
work you know you may think that you
know this you know doing these
particular things may work they may be
more complicated than you thought and so
it's what we you know in a very nerdy
way called the read and research you
know you do the experiment you have to
you know repeat the experiment make sure
it's you know validate the data make
sure it's actually what it says it is
and
so you spent a lot of time doing that
and you know it's and sometimes it's
slow so if you think about I think about
science like waves in the ocean right
you know sometimes its nose calm not a
lot going on and then you know you get a
wave in and that peak of the wave it's
like we're the most energy is and so you
you know you try to ride that wave as
long as possible that eventually the
wave dies out there's you know the space
between that wave in the next wave so
yeah the best-case scenarios that have a
lot of waves coming in but sometimes
it's little common you spend a lot of
time reading and trying to figure out
what you're doing so now you're so you
went to college you did research you
went to grad school and you did more
research and now you're in a post on
doing more research what are you going
to do next next I'm looking into
falconry positions so I want to work at
a university and and teach other
students to do the things that I've been
able to do it and recruit them and get
them excited about it um also very
incident policy so I what that means is
the trying to decide what we're going to
do research on uh where the funding is
what type of things we should do because
that the so bases para tide so the
priorities is what shape science its
plan state of money and they damage
money and that's that's amazing slices
expensive and so we need to as so one of
the things like a couple things I think
that scientists you spend more time
talking to the general public the public
through their tax dollars fund has
funded my research my entire career and
pretty much funds entire scientific
enterprise we call it but all the
science um and you know to spend time to
help the public understand what we're
doing and so we're doing a lot of cool
things and we should spend time helping
the public understand what we're doing
while we're doing it the other thing is
outreach so like I met
before when I started college there was
a limited number of careers that I knew
about and you know and that most people
think about one area and biology or
certain for science and other types of
sciences and so one of the things that I
want to do when I try to do as I spent
time doing we call our reach I interact
with students in local community other
types of groups to you know help them
with science and help kids get
interested in science because it's cool
um you know they're they're very few
things in life that like okay this is
why I love science so I I get paid to
think you know I get paid to learn stuff
I get paid to do experiments and try to
figure out things that no one else knows
and in most cases kids are very
interested in learning you know they're
inquisitive and I along with a few other
people we try to interact with students
to help boost that you know help
maintain an interest so I didn't so for
instance I didn't meet a scientist until
I was in college so I'm in you know late
teens early 20s the first time I
actually talked to scientists and that
was because they were my professors
however what I want to do is reach out
to students that are in elementary and
middle school high school and college
and and given an opportunity to meet
scientists from you know a very early
point and that means that they're
thinking about science a little
differently you know that they may my
goal is to try to recruit no students
from various backgrounds and and
socio-economic stakes to to get them to
get them interested in science and the
best way to do that is to go out and
interact with them and that's what you
find will be the same way of someone's
interested in becoming a carpenter you
don't all of a sudden get to your 20s
and you're interested in it you're
likely interested in it when you're a
kid you think it's cool to build stuff
and if you can meet a carpenter or meet
someone that can store
a teaching you and help you learn more
about it and get you engaged in it then
you your your interest peaks and bills
and then you can go into that as a
career and so I think is easier for
students to get into science if they
interact with scientists as early as
possible so you're already doing some
outreach stuff you're on you do a group
on Twitter called the dark side so what
is the dark side uh the dark side ha so
let's see so that's so this past we get
early in 2013 there are some other
scientists and journalists that I was
interacting with on Twitter and one of
the things that we were concerned with
is if you look at the african-american
community of when it comes to science
what we generally hear about is you know
the negative health implications you
know hi cancer rates high obesity
diabetes and always change life
expectancy and we were becoming a little
frustrated with media outlets on
particularly me two LS that cater to the
african-american community or minority
communities in that there has to be more
of a positive spin on this and to get
you know to get the communities
interested in science in general and the
science behind stories and and thinking
about health from a different
perspective because if you're if you're
constantly bombarded with the negative
you begin to internalize that versus
thinking about you know exactly what
does it mean to have this particular
health issue or so what are some of the
things you can do to prevent it and work
to change that those perceptions some
people to focus on you know positive
ways they can impact you know their
health as opposed to the negative things
that are happening exactly health or
just technology in general so for
instance I there there are some
statistics that if you look at social
media of women and minority women and
African Americans in general along with
other minority groups use social media
at a higher rate than whites and other
groups right so it is one in cases you
have minorities actually using this
these platforms more and so what that
means there's an opportunity to interact
and to get information directly to
people on social media they're so so
basically so if you think about it
usually science is going on at research
institutions and universities and so
unless you are near or have a way to get
into those institutions and universities
you don't really enter you don't have
like a connection of science so what we
so what we said is basically look we're
going to remove that barrier we're going
to go directly to people and so we
created our social circle to sorry you
use social media to help connect people
with science exactly so so I mentioned
before the the outreach and being
available so if someone's watching this
so when someone's watching this video
they can say well wait a minute okay I
don't understand some of the things that
dr. Wilson said so let me contact them
on Twitter okay so we start Twitter
conversation I can direct you to some
more information we can have some
conversations about it to you know help
you understand it and that could be
anyone I could be a student it can be a
teacher and a student teacher could be
you know from you know somewhere here in
Philadelphia they can be across the
country where they can be in another
country and I said that's the beauty of
social media is that it allows people to
interact that otherwise we would have no
way of accessing each other and so
eventually we we create an official name
for the dark side it's the National
Science and Technology new service and
so this the group of scientists and
journalists one of the things that we do
is we write articles about science
issues or
health-related issues and so and if the
overall goal is for the media outlets
that are the media outlets that want
these stories we're building the
repository so if someone's there's a
story about HIV or cancer in a certain
aspect and they want someone that's
doing that type of work or they can give
them an expert opinion they can reach
out to me or if they're looking at a
science communication and they can reach
out to dr. daniel lee or daniel e 5 so
there's so basically if someone saw us
if you have a question we have people
that can answer those questions so if
media outlets or editors want to reach
out to someone or if the public reads a
story that's like wait a minute arm
what's the deal with the story with gene
modified foods you know what's to deal
with what exactly is that we can put you
in contact with someone that can explain
that or a particular media outlets doing
a story on it we can put them in context
am I and the the major thing is for the
media outlets that are particularly
catering to minority communities what's
beneficial is you can actually find a
scientist or journalist that looks like
someone from that community right and so
that's a little bit easier because so as
a general example if you look at the
history of science and medicine in the
US um african-americans are a bit
skeptical because one of the things that
happen is people mentioned in Tuskegee
project and what that was is it was a
very bad chapter in medicine and science
were people in Tuskegee men in Tuskegee
Alabama were they had syphilis
infections or this bacterial infection
is very dangerous on as what's called a
sexy transmitted infection or sexy
transmitted disease and they weren't
treated so they were basically allowed
out disease allowed to progress and they
became very sick and have all the side
effects and problems that a complication
of lady to syphilis and so that
basically was done without their
knowledge yes exactly informed they were
given they were given syphilis and not
told and then not treated it was not not
a good time in American history exactly
and that that's the horrible part about
it wasn't hey ya is unknown you know I
think they were being treated and
various things going to but these men
were over peered over since 1930 to 1970
so almost 40 years of this happening and
so there's a bit of skepticism that
comes from that and so anytime someone
that's from outside the community is or
the various minority communities are
talking about health and health
playthings the skepticism is there
because of the the history and those
very horrible and it just you know
atrocious things that we're done so we
trust the medical community they haven't
done good things for us in the night
exactly and oftentimes the medical
community medical community did not look
like the community that you know the
community out there abroad or out there
in general so it's easier for you know
me to go in and have a conversation
because some of the skepticism won't be
there even though you know they may
think I'm a part of science or the
medical establishment I can have a
conference I can probably have a
conversation easier and get more to
having things flow and if it was someone
that didn't look like me or someone I
didn't look like that particular
community so where you're able to
connect people with experts that they
can identify with because I was two
experts that they may not necessarily
feel a kinship with exactly you know and
a lot of it comes down at Rice
if you want if we won underrepresented
communities of minority communities to
move more two and two different types of
science they have to trust you know
there's a lot like I mentioned before
the use of technology but to have
conversations about the impact of
science and health and you know various
other things that go on the communities
it's important you know to be able to
connect and I would say like on a like a
personal background you know we can have
conversations about you know various
aspects of life are growing up and if
you connect with someone's easy easy to
have a conversation the person does not
necessarily have to look like you or be
the same gender or be from the same you
know geographic region or country but if
you find a reason in a way to connect
with them the conversation usually is a
little bit easier and you can convey
some information so so we're trying to
you know do outreach through a dark side
and and try to increase the science
communication within underrepresented
communities in minority communities and
and also it's the diversified because
the conversations are different based on
my I'm gonna have conversations based on
my experiences you'll have current
stations based on yours and the next
person will have it based on theirs and
so if the conversation if I'm the only
person leading the conversation there's
only my perspective so it takes other
people to be involved in it to get a
perspective that's different from mine
so so I can say well okay I didn't think
about that but what you're saying makes
sense um this is a different way think
about maybe and we can improve health or
our general understanding of science
technology engineering mathematics based
on the experiences and so we all learn
from each other oh so we're running a
little bit out of time um but I just
wanted to know do you have any advice
for people who might think what you do
is really really cool and might be
interested in what you do and try to
have your career do you have any advice
for them as they seek a career in
science I would say try to learn as much
as possible so go on a social media so
if you're interested in
you know let's say for instance you're
interested in fighting heart disease or
something you want to be you know you
want to help people be healthier for
heart disease learn more about it use
social media reach out and find a
researcher that's doing that type of
work and have conversations with them
and you'll and where you'll find most of
the time through social media you can
basically an informal mentor you'll have
someone that can help guide your career
and help you help you learn from the
things that they've learned and also
avoid some of the mistakes that they
made so say find the information about
it read it but the hardest thing as a
scientist and translating saying go find
information is helping people understand
how to do it and in this age the easiest
way to do it is to find someone that's
doing what you may be interested in
doing and and trying to have a
conversation with them and social media
again is the easiest way you can send
the email and if you like me I get
hundreds of emails every day most of
them are you know not going to get
responded to because they're from
various things and I try to find the
point personal emails but that may be
slower but if you send me a tweet or if
you connect with me on my through G Plus
or facebook i have a facebook page
called first-generation stem because i'm
the first first generation person my
family to get into stem and the first
first person to get a PhD and so i'm
trying to you know encourage and pass
the information along to other
generation student but i would say use
social media scientists are out there we
are willing to have conversations and so
no totally like talking about people
yeah we love we love talking about
science if you don't love talking about
science it's kind of hard to do it I and
it's oftentimes a lot better and more
exciting to have conversations with
people that aren't anti-science as much
because then we have to make sure we're
communicating that science and so it's
easy to talk to another scientist
because we have what we call jargon and
you know we can talk about things that
the language that make sense to us but
we have to speak the language so you
know everyday folk to make sure that
they understand it and I like doing it I
like people to understand I'm doing not
just scientists but anyway so thank you
so much for coming on today and for
talking about your work um you can
contact dr. Wilson on Twitter as at hey
dr. Wilson I will also put up links to
his google plus account and to his
facebook for first-generation stem I'm
if you'd like to contact him to find out
more about what he does and how to
become a scientist thank you very much
gala you're welcome thank you for having
me thank you everybody